[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANKUR KOTWAL: Welcome to another
Backstage on making
apps beautiful.
This is part two after all five
parts of the DevBytes
series, Making Apps Beautiful,
have been released.
And I'm joined by--
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah,
I'm Jan-Felix Schmakeit.
I was here last time as well.
I'm based here in Sydney on
the Android Developer
Relations Team.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And I'm Ankur
Kotwal, and I'm a Software
Engineer on the Android
Developer
Relations Team as well.
We had some good discussions
last time, but we've had quite
a lot of questions since.
So let's talk about the elephant
in the room to begin
with, which is the
source code.
In Making Apps Beautiful, we
showed different stages of the
apps, the app that we were
building, and people were
asking if we were going to
release the source code.
And the answer is yes, we're
going to do that.
We're going to do that
very shortly.
I'm just cleaning it up and
preparing it so that you can
have a look.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah,
that's fantastic.
I think people are really
excited about this.
We didn't want to dig
through it again.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
We also had some followup
questions from the last--
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah.
We had a very popular question
on the cards layout that a lot
of people seem really
excited about.
And there's also a followup
question from the [INAUDIBLE]
who was asking a bit more
about the specifics of
implementing a cards layout
that's dynamic, so you could
have different size
cards together.
And I thought about this a bit
more, and I think that there's
lots of different ways
you can do this.
One way we've done it is
that we have actually
used our own ViewGroup.
So if you want to have something
that's a bit more
abstract, you can just add
your own content to it.
I think there's a bit
more work involved.
You would actually have to
look at [INAUDIBLE] a
ViewGroup, doing your own
measurements and layouts, and
all that kind of stuff.
But if it's just something as
simple as displaying different
size content and it's just
a list, basically, just a
resizable layout might just do
the trick, and the 9-patch in
the background.
So there might be a bit more
work involved, but simply
using a 9-patch and different
size containers
might work for you.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
And then just to followup as
well, the person was asking
about a 48 dp rhythm.
Now for when you're talking
about something that's similar
to the cards layout, 48 dps,
just have a look at it.
It might not be quite right
because typically a lot of
these cards, you tend to have
some rich content, and you
have some buttons that you
can press as well.
And if you try to squash all of
that information into a 48
dp layout, you might find that
you don't have enough space.
So I wouldn't say that you
need to follow the 48 dp
rhythm for cards layout
to the letter.
See what works well, and
provide the better user
experience.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: And if
you think about how these
cards layouts have been used
in the past, for example in
the Play Store, there's always
a big touch target.
In this case, it's generally the
application icon, or the
movies icon, or something.
Always something big
you can hit.
So it's something to keep
in mind when you
design a user interface.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
OK.
So, yeah, thanks.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Thanks for
that followup question.
It was good.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah,
the [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
So we had some questions around
the layout XML files
that we had in the
tablets episode.
The questions were actually
around using references rather
than just putting in your sw600
dp resource folders.
So do we want to sort of--
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah, so
one big reason for this is
that you don't want to duplicate
your layouts, right?
So if you want to reuse your
layouts, it's just much easier
to just use references rather
than copy and pasting the
files multiple times in the APK,
and it would blow up the
APK as well.
But there's another
reason as well.
Before Android API level 13--
it's Android 3.2, Honeycomb--
you only had these buckets that
allowed you to look at
the screen size, the actual
screen size, of the device.
So like small, normal, large,
and extra large screens.
So a tablet would be
an extra large
screen bucket, for example.
And the problem is this really
didn't give you fine-grained
control, because sometimes
some devices would get
classified as extra large, but
they're actually a phone, for
example, right?
It was really tricky to take
this apart and actually
provide a tablet-only layout
and a phone-only layout.
So API level 13 and above, we
actually introduced some
resource modifiers that you
can use to look at the
available screen size.
You can look at the smallest
[INAUDIBLE] that's available
on the device, and it doesn't
change for rotation.
So in this case, when you want
to define a layout for a Nexus
7, for example, like a 7-inch
tablet, you will look at 600
dp, or a 10-inch tablet
would be 720 dp.
So that's really
useful as well.
So this is where these
references come in really
handy, where you can just
reuse your layouts in
different ways.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
Just to add to that as well,
with the qualifiers that we
added, you'll notice that
they're now numerical.
So you're talking about
measurements.
You're talking about physical
sizes of devices.
Whereas before, when you had
these arbitrary buckets, it
was getting hard to classify a
device in large or extra large
because one of the strengths
of the Android ecosystem is
the variety of screen sizes.
So you can get small tablets and
large phones that could be
large, extra large, it
could be medium.
Whereas when you talk about
these qualifiers, when you say
600 dp, you're now putting a
physical measurement around
the dimensions of that device.
So that's why it works
a lot better.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, exactly.
And it's also important to
note that this is the
available size.
So is this the size that's
actually available to your
application?
We're not just talking about
the physical, the actual
screen size anymore.
We're talking about what's
actually available for your
application.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Great.
So, do we need resources
for every combination?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Not necessarily.
Good question.
[LAUGHTER]
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: The Android
framework actually
takes care of this for you, so
it tries to take a good guess
at what are the best resources
for you to use if you don't
specify it for every
single combination.
So for example, if you specify a
phone layout and you specify
a 7-inch tablet using the 600
dp resource quantifier.
And you don't specify a 10-inch
layout, you know, a
bigger tablet layout.
It would automatically pick the
one that goes for the 600
dp for the 7-inch tablet.
So it tries to make
a good guess at
what's useful for you.
And you can use it to your
advantage, right?
So I think it's a good idea to
look at what's specific to
some of your layouts and how
you can trim down on the
layouts and resources and
images that you use.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
I mean, typically we tend to
use the 10-inch qualifier,
which is 720 dp, the 7-inch
qualifier which is 600 dp, and
then just not putting
a qualifier,
which is your fallback.
So you've got phone,
7-inch tablets,
10-inch tablets as well.
So they tend to cater
for really
the bulk of the devices.
Unless you're going for
something very specialized,
which generally we don't
recommend because
maintainability becomes
more difficult.
But yeah, three buckets
will get you very far.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
That's right.
We talked a tiny bit about
designing for platform
independence in our series.
We had the Nexus S. We
had a tablet layout.
We had a phone layout.
So let's talk a bit about
this a bit more.
So do you have any good tips?
When you want to design a
layout, you want to design an
app for platform independence,
what are the key things you
should pay attention
to or that you
should do in your code?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Just to clarify,
by platform, what we actually
meant is device independence,
so we're not linked to a
particular device size.
But when you're specifying
layouts, the obvious thing is
use dps, use density
independent pixels.
They're physical measurements.
We have some great documentation
about this, so
please check it out at
d.android.com if you're not
sure
But we also have a special
qualifier or unit of
measurement called sp.
Sp is actually what you should
be using for things like
TextViews because they're
telling you that the text that
you have in these things like
TextViews, you're going to
scale that up based on
the user preferences.
So for example, if the user has
got their accessibility
settings set so that the
smallest font size is a
minimum of 14 rather than 12,
then sp will honor that,
whereas dps won't.
So for text, use sp's.
For everything else, use dps.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah.
And what about pixels?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Pixels?
Never use pixels.
Never hard code pixel values
in your layout.
Now obviously, your assets
will tend to have pixels.
Your images will be using a
pixel coordinate system.
There's a very simple
mapping to dps.
But we already talked in Making
Apps Beautiful, those
DevBytes, about how you can use
those images well, so that
they kind of stretch nicely,
they may crop.
So we use centerCrop in all of
the examples that we used.
So yeah, definitely.
And you should always, to go
with pixels, make sure you
don't use absolute layouts.
Absolute layouts were in a
very early version of the
platform and were deprecated
a long time ago.
Our compiler will warn
you about it, so
please heed those warnings.
The other thing is make sure you
provide images or assets
for the different densities, so
that at runtime the device
isn't having to scale
up a low resolution
image on an xhdpi device.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, exactly.
That's actually what's happening
when you put in an
image asset and you provide it
in a xhdpi or mdpi resource
folder, but you're not
specifying anything for ldpi
or any other resources.
It would actually get scaled
up or scaled down.
We use extra work for the device
itself, so maybe not
such a good idea.
So it's always a good idea to
put these in and process them
beforehand.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And taking that
one step further, quite a lot
of apps will dynamically
download images right from the
web, so try and provide those
assets on your server or
whatever content you're getting
so that it comes down
in the right resolution.
Or when you fetch it, make sure
you do the conversion, so
that you're not having to do
it at runtime, but just the
one download cost at the time
you download it for the
relevant resolution.
All right, so we had some
more questions as well.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Actually,
before we go on, let's see it
there's anyone on the Hangout.
If you have any questions,
feel free to join
our Hangouts on air.
There's a link post
on our Plus page.
So if you have any questions,
feel free to just post it in
chat, and we'll put you up on
the screen if you want to be
live on air.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, so you can
still ask questions and not
come on the screen
if you like.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
No pressure.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, there's
no pressure.
People feel shy.
While we wait for people to ask
us questions, we do have
others that people submitted.
Antonio said, "I'd like to know
what do you think about
using different fonts?"
Basically, he was saying what if
I don't want to use Roboto,
and I want to use
a custom font?
To be honest, the answer is you
can use whatever font you
like, but at the end of the
day, make sure you've
considered the different
aspects of the
type of font you use.
So does it look great on a
3-inch phone screen, but does
it blow up well onto
a 10-inch tablet?
Does it support different
languages, accented
characters, and so on?
So by all means, we do encourage
you to use your own
fonts and ship them with
your app if you'd like.
Don't make assumptions
about which fonts
are going to be available.
So other than Roboto
and Droid Sans.
Don't make assumptions about
what users are going to have.
But Antonio said he was from
Spain, so perhaps there's a
particular font that works
well for the accented
characters that you
get in Spanish.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
That's actually an
important point as well.
When you're adding custom font,
you have to make sure it
supports other international
characters as well, especially
if you have [INAUDIBLE]
app, where you want to reach
users in other countries and
other languages.
So when you add a custom font,
make sure it works for all
your languages that your
app is relevant
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
OK.
We had Leander Berg also asking
a question, saying,
"For tablet optimizations, Nick
Butcher"-- he said Nick,
but I'm pretty sure it's Nick
Butcher-- "has some
interesting tips for
his Design Bytes.
He had a grid view in tablets
and a list view on phones.
How would I implement this?
Is it always a grid view, just
with different layouts?
Or would I switch between
the two?"
Actually, the option's yours.
You could just go with a single
grid view that's one
column on phones and
multi-columns on a tablet, or
you could switch them around.
And basically, what you would
do is using those same
resource qualifiers, you could
have a value that indicated
whether you're in the
grid view mode or
the list view mode.
And conditionally in your code,
when you do a find view
by ID, you would cast them
to the right type.
So actually, there is no
right way to do it.
There's multiple ways
to do it, which is
always a good thing.
I mean, it makes sense to use
grid views on tablets because
especially if you're doing like
a tiled UI, you want to
be able to use that extra space
that you get on tablets.
OK.
So we had some episodes on
performance tuning, and we
talked in our episode a little
bit about LruCache, the least
recently used cache.
It's great, and I hope more and
more people are using it.
Because as you saw in our
episode, it makes a massive
difference to the performance of
your app and the experience
as well, and it tries to do
the right thing by holding
onto your images as
long as possible.
So the hard work is
done for you.
It's just a matter
of utilizing it.
But there is some other
libraries that
you can use to fetch--
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah.
So we didn't talk in our
series, but there are
obviously a lot of other
libraries you can use to fetch
images, do some processing
of the UI, and all
that kind of stuff.
So you don't have to do all of
the work yourself every single
time you want to do something.
One really good library
that we have been
using is called Volley.
There was a talk at Google I/O
this year that I would highly
recommend for you guys
to check out.
It's a library that's open
source and is part of the
Android framework as well.
ANKUR KOTWAL: We use
it extensively.
It's actually written
by a Googler, Ficus,
and yeah, it's great.
It asynchronizes your
web requests.
And so you can basically have
a very responsive user
interface that brings
images in in the
background, for example.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
It's actually very
easy to use, actually.
You basically say here's an
image, here's the URL, here's
the view where I
want to put it.
And it goes off, does it
automatically, and updates the
UI in the right track, and
does all this kind
of stuff for you.
It's really handy.
But you can also use it for
other things, not just images.
So for example, built
in, I think,
support for JSON as well.
So if there's some JSON you want
to fetch from a server,
you can use the Volley library
for that as well, and it gives
you back the JSON option, the
JSON array, and it's really,
really handy.
And there are all sorts of other
really cool features in
there, folks.
For example, does location
for you has really good
cancellation policies.
If you want to stop requests,
you can group them together
and all that kind of stuff.
I highly recommend checking
that out.
Having said that, there are a
lot of other libraries out
there as well that people are
using these days as well, and
one of the ones was Picasso that
somebody mentioned in a
YouTube comment.
So have a look at your app and
see which library does exactly
what you need to do.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yep.
So that's Picasso, not
Picasa, like the
photo app and website.
And I guess the good news since
we recorded the episode
is that ActionBarCompat
is finally out.
When we recorded it, we were,
like, "coming soon." But its
great, it's released, and it's
part of the support library.
So please grab it, use
it, let us know what
you think about it.
We also have a DevByte on using
ActionBarCompat, so it's
a good way to get you started.
It's a good primer.
Now we've had some questions
around, well, should I use
ActionBarCompat?
Should I use ActionBarSherlock?
ActionBarSherlock,
widely popular.
We talked about it in
our DevByte as well.
So if you're comfortable with
ActionBarSherlock, go ahead,
keep using it.
Both are great libraries, so
use what works for you.
What we're going to be doing is
as we update the ActionBar
in the Android framework--
let's say we do it in a future
version of the Android
framework--
we're going to make sure that
ActionBarCompat is also kept
up to date.
So that's one of the things that
you'll get straight away
from ActionBarCompat.
But you know, use what
works well for you.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: That's
right, that's right.
The navigation drawer is
obviously an interesting
topic, and we kind of showed
it off in beta, I think, in
one of our last episodes
that he did.
And that's part of the
software library
as well, isn't it?
ANKUR KOTWAL: It is.
You can grab the classes.
You can just drop it in
and start using it.
The nice thing is we talked
about all of the subtleties
that come with the standardized
Android
ActionBar, and you get those.
You don't need to sit down
implementing the nice,
beautiful fade in, fade out
or the bezel swipes.
It's all taken care
of for you.
Using standard components
is always a good thing.
You don't have to write it and
test the code yourself.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
That's right.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK.
The last think I think we should
talk about-- we didn't
really talk about it--
is notifications.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah.
That's in NotificationCompat and
support library as well.
So in Android 4.1, Jelly Bean,
we introduced new types of
notifications.
So you can have expanded
You can display a different type
of notification depending
on whether it's expanded
or not expanded.
It's really useful for email
messages, for example.
You can see all of your emails
in unification lists, so you
can minimize them and
only see that you
have some unread messages.
And this is something that
we've added to the
NotificationCompat in the
support library as well.
But the problem here is that
expanded notifications are not
backwards compatible.
So if you use the
NotificationCompat builder
that's in the support library,
you can add all of these
things to your notification, but
it doesn't get displayed
on lower versions of Android,
unfortunately.
But the good thing for you, it's
transparent, so you don't
have to worry about version
checks and all
that kind of stuff.
It simply isn't displayed.
One really big hint I have,
though, is that if you make
use of these expanded
notifications or notification
actions-- you know how you can
have buttons at the bottom of
notifications.
You can reply straight
away or call someone
back straight away--
make sure you always supply
a content intent.
And the content intent is the
one that's fired when you use
a taps notification.
This is basically what gets
fired on lower versions of
Android, so Gingerbread,
for example.
We don't have support for these
notification actions, right?
So it's always really, really
important to specify the
content intent that gets fired
off when somebody taps your
notification.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Well, it doesn't
look like we have anyone
asking any questions
on the Hangout.
I think we've covered the
questions that we had leading
up to this.
So on that note, I guess
we'll say goodbye.
Thank you for joining us.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, thank you.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And we'll
see you next time.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
See you next time.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Bye bye.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]